mientras la guerra continúa en Ucrania y
cuando kiev se prepara para una
contrafensiva en primavera los
comentarios del embajador de china en
Francia han provocado la indignación de
toda Europa
en su aparición en el Canal de noticias
francés
lcize se negó a decir será crimea
anexionada Era De hecho parte de Ucrania
luego pasó a decir que los países que
surgieron después de la caída de la
unión soviética no tienen estatuto
efectivo en virtud del derecho
internacional porque no hay ningún
acuerdo internacional que confirme su
condición de Naciones soberanas
estos comentarios ponen entre dicho no
sólo Ucrania sino a todas las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas que surgieron como
naciones independientes tras la caída de
la unión soviética en 1991 El lunes los
líderes de las tres naciones bálticas de
la Unión Europea Estonia letonia y
lituania convocaron a los enviados de
China para que explicaran sus
comentarios
pedir una aclaración si ha cambiado la
posición de China sobre la independencia
y recordarle que no somos países
posopiéticos somos los países que fueron
ocupados ilegalmente por la unión
soviética el máximo responsable de
política exterior de la Unión Europea
josep borrell calificó de inaceptables
las declaraciones del enviado chino y
dijo que el bloque también quería una
explicación el lunes el Ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de Beijing trató de
calmar la polémica retractándose de los
comentarios del embajador la posición de
China sobre las cuestiones relevantes no
ha cambiado china respeta el estatus de
soberanía de los países de la antigua
Unión soviética tras la disolución de la
unión soviética no es la primera vez que
elu desata la polémica en 2021 se peleó
en las redes sociales con un
investigador francés al que llamó
pequeño matón y troll también ha
remitido contra un grupo de legisladores
franceses que se plantean viajar a
Taiwán que china considera parte de su
territorio